today I was going to meet a friend and I  went walking up Farwell Avenue here in  Milwaukee I thought I would give you a  little Glimpse about what it looks like  because this is where I used to live  this is shank Hall a uh Concert Hall  where a lot of bands play we're walking  up far well and I'm not sure what this  is but it's clearly under construction  and then we go a little bit further and  as we get around this corner there it is  the apartment building full of studio  apartments that I lived in in 1994 and  1995 paid 280 a month for this spot and  you know for a single guy who was  working a lot of jobs it wasn't too bad  you see that there and I'm going to show  you a little bit more and that's the  street that's the place I used to live